all right here we go with the last lift
lift number four remember this is
interchangeable with lift number three
the back squat okay so first how to uh
position your feet and address the bar
so we want our feet straight not out so
use your middle toe uh point that right
foot a little more straight okay and
you're in shisen so the feet are
underneath his hips
okay and you use that knurling on the
bar to be symmetrical in the bar
and now he's going to slow down please
he's going to position the bar roll it
backwards towards him so it's under his
midfoot now sometimes you can step under
there yourself um but you can also roll
it back to you just don't lift it yet
okay so it's on your
midfoot and then we use this um Knuckles
forward symmetrical grip we don't do the
over undergrip because it'll it's going
to uh cultivate your upper body strength
asym ically so we just lift like this
okay what he's going to do is shoot his
hips backwards okay his torso will adopt
that same 45° angle that's in the back
squat and the way to look at this is
he's trying not to bring his knees
forward he's trying to leave them in
place so his hips are back and then what
he does is he's going to keep this back
posture and this whole organization for
as long as possible through the lift
until he actually has to straighten his
torso uh as he brings it up so the
midfoot is the weight resistance line he
tries to bring it up that midfoot line
and then it goes right back down that
midfoot line okay so I'm going to have
him do finish this set of five okay we
don't slam it at the
bottom we place it
[Music]
and that's the deadlift